I recently was reading huh sex is very
available for you for everybody no no
that's not that's not that's not true
what no no one out of one out of one out
of three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year under
three because they are aiming for a when
if they settled for D no no I promise
you no
statistically women women far easier to
have sex find sex and it's only a small
percentage you get the majority of women
even even women that are very
unattractive are still very picky of
course yeah right so that's what I'm
saying if they're picky they're not
picking a large percentage of men the
standard has dropped there are more
women in situationships
right but with a with a small percentage
of men so like the reason they think
like men are trash is because they're
all screwing the same ones so so it's
like it's like a very small percentage
of men are screwing everybody's yeah it
is on Tinder just sitting in their house
waiting to get tapped into the game so
they can be that guy as well yeah for
the statistics for Tinder uh men swipe
uh is it right yes
right 60 of the time whereas women swipe
right three percent of the time so it's
like they're very very selective
compared to men yeah
how many guys have moved to you this
week
[Laughter]
but I feel like the way guys present
themselves they are not they they are
reflecting a reality that is not so them
because guys act like yeah I get girls
yes
that's not that's not true it's only the
guys you pay attention to that yeah it's
only the guys you pay attention to
because
you don't you don't you don't notice the
guy at Nando's working I'm sorry it's
disingenuous it's just it's just I mean
you say thank you but you're not really
checking for him thinking does he get
girls you know deep down he doesn't you
know and like women we just know this
stuff and you can you could walk into a
room you as a girl you know who's
getting laid you know who's knocking you
don't have to sit they don't have to say
[__] you know who's telling the truth
in around with guys they're they're
although there are plenty of guys who
don't do this there is a percentage of
guys who massively inflate the idea of
how many girls
that's you're not wrong but like I I
went to like a pickup boot camp once and
it's basically where they teach guys how
to get laid and so I could see I could
see the uh the extremes it was really
interesting it was kind of like like
seeing what they teach the boys
they have them here too yeah yeah
um it's it's a very big kids
no it's a really big Community like they
they pay thousands of dollars to fly
into a city yeah and and learn from guys
that know how to get laid how to get
laid okay
because that's how that's how like
lonely they are but because they they
don't even know what it's like to have a
girl like look at them and be in they
girl excited to talk to them because we
don't we don't feel that guy and you're
on eight figures
yeah the thing is yeah on the real one
yeah it's all laughing and joking but
that's real to them that's their life
you look like a laughing joke because
you don't even understand that life
you know what it's like to get rejected
by a small percentage of guys but you
don't know what it's like to get
rejected by everybody because you know
you try no more yeah you know if you
walk outside
like they don't even if you walk outside
and say anyone have sex with me you'll
have takers
yeah but you know what I'm saying like
those guys if they said that they would
be looked at like they're crazy and they
probably have the police called yeah 100
now or sections right and that's and
that's the thing at that boot camp I
could see very extreme ends because you
had the guys that were teaching the boot
camp that get laid all the time and the
guys that were going that that didn't
that didn't even know how to talk to me
like I couldn't even have a non like
they could barely have a conversation
with me were they nervous yeah yeah
they're awkward I mean some like oh my
gosh I have stories from like there's
this one guys this one guy was telling
me how he's gonna conquer the world
like he wanted to be like a you know
that's that's a different thing but
there is some
um
yeah and it was but the the instructors
I saw them take
probably five girls home in three days
come on yeah five girls and so and so
each of those girls would think that
she's on that instructor's level but I I
mean they weren't all pretty sorry but
they were there men and men and women
there to pick up oh yeah come on you
need a you need a you need a class do
you go outside and say does anyone want
to have sex just do this
foreign
Zone
[Laughter]
yes oh friends I have a dungeon for them
okay when they try to keep escaping I
put them in the block dungeon why why
don't you why don't you just cut them
off and tell them it's never gonna
happen yeah that's why they're in the
dungeon they when you go over that
boundary of it's not gonna happen and
you still kind of come at me I put you
in prison which is the dungeon on the
block list of WhatsApp do they consent
to this they don't they do they're in
the doctor they have no idea you're in
prison now like you don't so is that the
plot list yeah but then annually twice a
year I have like parole reviews
reoffend you go back in for a Life
Center okay do not see what a privileged
position that is
in the sexual Marketplace to be in a
position where you're just blocking
people and choosing if you want to go
back to them but the thing is it's
draining it is very draining I haven't
been trying to say this since I was 12.
it is I'm I'm tired yeah but one day you
realize one day it's gonna go away and
you're gonna miss it because no one's
checking for girls at 50. my mom is
quite pretty and she's 63. she's good
looking okay well I've got a leeway but
I get what you're saying your sexual
market value does it decrease as you get
older yeah so it's like I got one one
day you're gonna be like I missed the
cat calls
every year though like I'm getting old
you'll be like where's the key to that
dungeon
fact and you're gonna be like ah I
remember when I was on that podcast and
I was talking a load of crap
all right
why why did they end up in the dungeon
why
um some just wanted sex for me I don't
want that
so why don't you just cut them off
completely blocked like that and they
kept coming back how how no I told you
some make parole because I give you a
second chance so basically I'm not
actually cutting them off I don't talk
to them I unblock them they don't know
they're unblocked it's only if they
maybe
my status I'm just thinking like I don't
want to hold people in my dungeon I want
to release the Faith attention is
currency that's why I don't care about
that I don't want them we'll be talking
my opinion is that why are literally
talking to guys that when you are in
such a situation yeah move out of that
situation I do but sometimes I'm saying
that we guys should talk to other guys
you know if a lady is telling you um no
yes all right later I'll talk to you
later and you move on not even talk too
late just end yeah
so I have a question yeah you said that
sex is too readily available yes okay so
like what
don't you think like the only way to
make it unreadly available is to get
married young agreed okay 100 agreed and
to state
your goal because a lot of people are
dating without a definitive intention
yeah yeah and we were having this
conversation there's no courtship
anymore dating and courtship are two
different courtship means
um marriage is the goal we'd like to get
there let's figure out how to navigate
our way on this journey to reach the end
goal whereas dating is like
The Crystal Maze yeah you might open and
there might be a trap door you might
fall down a well is that the man's sport
is it a woman's photo I think that we're
both sexes are contributing to this
issue and women are on this I'm a
feminist sexual freedom and the truth is
they are they're not happy yeah they're
missing themselves but they don't want
to admit that they're not happy because
then to admit that would mean that
actually you've been changed [__] for
the last 10 years but they're not ready
to let that go so I think women as well
just be honest you're not enjoying the
experience you're not enjoying the
experience biologically do you know when
you have sex as a woman something called
the limbic system makes you connect
emotionally to a man that is biological
that even if you say yeah no feelings
I'm just lashing and dashing
if he hits that wait let me look at the
Caribbean hits that spot
no you will connect if you keep doing
something over and over again it becomes
habit that's human behavior you will
have to some degree if wait bearing in
mind if she likes your personality yeah
she will emotionally connect with you
yeah if she likes you even if you've got
whack PP if she commitment
she won't cheat because she wants excuse
me
he's probably not the first guy that
she's beat bro yeah so she's probably
beat a man before that was pretty good
yeah she's had the Tyrone before she had
eight inches before Tyrone is doing it
so like he's my man yeah he's got creep
personality he makes you laugh but every
time it's bedtime he's got the Shadows
here we go
all it takes is the next Tyrone to call
you up
and she's in she loves him she's
accepted that he's not gonna blow the
back out she hasn't got the high
expectations
for girls if a girl's with a guy and
it's not if she doesn't think it's the
best she can do they usually leave after
they get the kids or what the resources
that they want I'm not gonna lie the guy
takes care of her they're really good
friends they have excellent
communication I think she's seen that
you know yeah
so she's probably doing a cuckold no no
she has sex with him
yeah yeah
and the girl hollered me to blow her
back out in front of her boyfriend and
her boyfriend's like yeah because you
can't Supply the goods wow I hear their
surgeries wait wait wait wait what oh
are you I told the story before
and
I said I told the story before I haven't
told this story before
come on okay so so basically so how did
this start how did you get her number
so I'm at University last year my first
Festival in fact I'm a third year I'm
like you know what if I go back to the
ends I ain't gonna get a chance to do
Festival things I did a festival thing
we're not getting it you know yeah
you're from nuts yes I went to Disney
see this girl twerking in the middle of
the freaking field I'm thinking what I'm
gonna go catch that one yeah so I'll
leave everyone like the way I'm catching
that way boom it's a nice time to you
know what the dance has done so your
balance we telling me what's going on
right now she was my boyfriend's behind
you
I said what who left it there that's the
end of that story
a few years down the line yeah it's it's
uh no not yet well actually no I'm in
second year it's third year now next
year
um we're having a house party freshest
week I get a text on my phone I open up
I see a nude it's like Eddie want to
come over
we ain't smoking you know bearing your
mind I've seen I've seen the luxury the
skills look I said yeah and I'm drunk
I'm finished it's fresh as weak so she's
like listen I've already owed you on
Uber it's outside wow seriously yeah so
as I'm driving I'm getting more news
come free but what I'm not realizing is
that she's not the one holding the
camera
[Music]
so I have I've arrived at this
destination yeah and I've seen a girl
come in a big jacket obviously nothing
underneath and then I walk in I see a
guy doing coconut corner I'm not wait so
hello my name's obviously I call them
Tony
I'll call him Tony he's a teacher
they're both School teachers the game's
all [__] up
so he's we're just talking now we'll get
to know as many of you
have you just ban
Tick Tock and demonetized on a day
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible